preacher pick interdict specifics about
the South Pacific 60 millionth movie
about King Kong decides to work in
Icarus too because this new monster
verse is fast bullshit the plane crashed
4 seconds before this asshole landed
right beside the wreckage young Hank
displays his incredible stormtrooper aim
even though he could literally walk
right up to the other currently unarmed
pilot and shoot him point-blank
propaganda raishin mark my words they'll
never be a more screwed up time in
Washington har-har but this attempt at a
cheap laugh could literally be put into
any political era and everyone would
knowingly chuckle hence the cheap part
hang on they've been sitting in gridlock
in this cab for who knows how long but
they've been right in front of their
destination maybe now's not the best
time ask monarch is on the cusp of being
shut down Brooke this walk and talk
reminds me that this is a conversation
they should have had much earlier than
now many civilizations spoke Overton
legends Skull Island roll credits a land
where God did not finish creation as you
can see from the pictures it's a
ceaseless void where time and space did
not exist you can also see some of God's
power tools strewn about it's
notoriously the number of ships and
planes that have gone missing there just
out of curiosity of a landmass has this
most of the reputation why is it just
now being discovered lands that is
sending a mission to the island we could
piggyback on that operation there's some
other government organization already
going to the island to explore the why
the hell would the senator even need
monarch to tag along I don't believe I'm
saying this but that almost makes sense
senator would almost be amazing at
cinemasins
[Music]
it's said that there are no songs from
the Vietnam era that don't sound like a
song from the Vietnam era cliche movies
anymore
in case you confused it with the
donating Air Force Base in Des Moines
Iowa this scene is sponsored by cases
and cases and a few bottles of Budweiser
and so was this samuel l.jackson
introduction i know you just left your
office but we thought it would be more
cinematically pleasing for you to take
this call in a phone booth in the ring
looks like this movie spent habbits
budget on rain machines and made sure
key scenes took place with them involved
so we couldn't hear the dialogue also
considering the amount of expediting
they do right before arriving places I
assume these guys travel in total
silence until they're less than hundred
feet away from their destination as if
on cue James gets into a fight to show
off his survival skills right in front
of guys who were going to hire him for
that very thing for chat irony in case
you confused it for Bangkok main you're
not actually gonna blame the people
without guns for losing the war are you
here's one of the main problems with
this fucking movie seems like everyone
has a manufactured conflict or bond
after the first time they meet or our
show and then it doesn't pay off in any
way as our satellites show the island is
surrounded by a perpetual storm system
allowing it to remain hidden from the
outside world it's a lot like that TV
show lost
anyone remember lost here well you will
an accompanied by biologist Miss Ann
biologist is conveniently hot so that
I'll keep watching this oh that's the
same chick from the great wall and holy
this movie made about the same amount of
money in China that movie did anyway
this movie's blatant attempt to placate
a Chinese audience is totally wasted in
this movie she has a couple lines and
nothing dude will use explosives to
shake the earth and create vibrations
helping us to map the subsurface of the
island the way Brooks is presenting this
plan sounds ludicrous enough that
someone should ask him why the fuck you
would use explosives to map the island
but the real bolt is even both
considering random Brooks agree that
this is the best strategy to find some
prehistoric wildlife rather than you
know exploring the island without
fucking bombing once on the island
the storms interference a black hole
radio contact with the ship truthfully
I'm just excited to be playing another
role besides the motion capture rape
this time you distract me as a blue OVA
tog refer anti-war photographer man
they'll let anyone on this fucking
mission why they she put a known
anti-war photographer be invited to
shoot a government-funded military
assisted exploration but as field
supervisor of the controlling agency I
say we abort that's it we're gonna abort
this asshole wants to abort the entire
mission that they plan so intricately
just because the storm looks old
worse than they thought it would there
is no way I'm getting on that helicopter
by the movies even bother with this
bullshit anymore luckily a Mason wander
store the helicopter that's meant for
hot people only as usual remember also
that's the truth Ruth and I will strike
down upon thee with great vengeance and
furious anger and I'm here to talk to
you about the Avengers initiative gauges
levers soldiers excitement if this is
truly the land where God did not finish
creation why the hell did they have
regular ass seagulls on this island
everything else seems to be deadly
except for these regular ass seagulls
I don't care how many loudspeakers you
rigged up to this chopper there's no way
anyone's hearing that over all these
rotors goddamn these stupid fucking
bombs and they're unopposed use in this
fucking movie hey we just found the one
island that's been uncharted throughout
all of civilization
now let's immediately bomb the fuck out
of it Cole's not excited about the bombs
going off he's just happy that the
director chose him for the obligatory
destruction reflecting off sunglasses
shot the pilot who has basically one job
somehow fails to see this tree flying in
slow motion towards them and does
nothing to evade it would it have killed
you to show the guy falling into Kong's
mouth there was that too gruesome
considering later you have a graphic
shot of a guy getting impaled by a
spider leg helicopters most of which
contain civilians who are now just
seeing the large and dangerous
prehistoric ape continue to fly right at
the large and dangerous prehistoric ape
and a monkey the twist is it's actually
you several people survive this the guy
yelling did not go to the Prometheus
school running away from things but his
partner guess where he went so is it a
sunset or not because most of the shots
are in full light and some are lit like
this also why would the Sun be shining
at all the island is surrounded by a
perpetual storm that no one can
penetrate so it should be cloudy every
goddamn day movies are art so did Kong
slam this helicopter to explode in a
fashion by which the flames would create
the symmetrical stare down between
Packard and Kong probably not it's just
a visual expressing itself in a manner
pleasing to our eyes and brains but I'm
sending it anyway because I'm a dick who
takes things literally and Packard
should be dead Conrad's arrived this
helicopter crash so easily that he's
been cast in the next Suicide Squad
movie I don't know what that was either
um well it's not too hard to tell right
it's a giant gorilla yeah yeah I've seen
something like that before but I mean
that's what you think it is right really
not gonna talk about it you know this is
not normal right stuff like that doesn't
just happen I don't have much to say
about Captain Obvious here so I'm just
gonna insert something into this video
real quick
oh yeah that's the stuff cold what's
wrong with you how do you even right now
I'm going to guess in the script that
Jason Mitchell's character was not
called Mills but guy who's always
comically yelling at character as of yet
undefined and the dialogue was written
in coffee stains we just got taken down
Bob monkey the size of a build and
apparently he just pieced the fuck out
afterwards even though you guys are
being incredibly loud and that's what he
apparently got pissed off about the
first place you
I'm going to tell me everything I don't
know I'm going to blow your head off
monsters exist no if I were to find one
example to sum up this movie screenplay
it's this exchange one of a thousand
young men on that ship I was the only
survivor
careful bill I'm here Elijah price is
looking for a guy like that my agency is
known as monarch we specialized in the
hunt for massive unidentified
terrestrial organisms exactly did
monarch find that kept the US government
funding it for 30 years
if Randa is a crackpot then there never
was any real proof of monsters and the
government decided to keep throwing
money at this for no reason they were
giving out wings yeah this clear the
mouths of lion and the thorn you do know
that story is about a mouse becoming
friends with a lion after taking the
thorn out of his pocket right it wasn't
that mouse kills a lion with the thorn
giant spiders somehow went unnoticed
until now even though he's got giant
bamboo like legs as soon as this guy
dies we hear nothing but and it's this
giant spider materialized out of nothing
before he started stomping on everybody
do they need to kill this thing just run
all these giant dangerous prehistoric
creatures appear exactly once a piece in
this movie 62 percent of this movie is
comprised of Samuel Jackson's patented
vengeance eyes Nils head is completely
clean here despite just being good right
the face by the giant death bug a few
seconds ago yeah but why this native
give the position away just by opening
their eyes it completely negates the
surprise element and considering they
live with Marlo who has a gun they
should know that people with guns have
an advantage what's this dickhead doing
while all the natives were about to
attack was he off peeing somewhere when
all this started you don't want to be
out here at night why the hell not the
only time we don't see a surprise attack
in this movie is at night that wall is
that supposed to keep out that thing
well it did a great job until they
discover the town today we're digging
tunnels underneath it and I was trying
to send two movies at once there and
that's what happens you get two
completely different movies mixed up
sometimes
Tom Hilson is desperately trying to hide
his I just did this bull for a large
paycheck but I'm still a respected
British actor face here where they tell
it for thousands of years the people on
this island lived in fear man it sure is
lucky that the natives took in Hank and
he survived all these years so the
twenty nine years later these people
could understand the world of Kong
better and one
the damnedest thing happened some of the
things they were afraid of started
protecting them against the things that
were eating them why nobody knows seems
like a creature like Kong wouldn't care
one whit about a bunch of humans getting
slayed by giant monsters but I guess
it's also he could be the good guy
wasn't Kong the one who killed your
friend no one of them did but you'll
have to wait until you're in perfect
position to view this 3d art before you
can tell who one of them is they come
from the vents that's why conga so mad
those bombs woke up a bunch of all seems
like the natives along with her buddy
Kong could have built walls around the
vets so that they could contain them
ever even sealed the vents
also is this an unusual occurrence for
them to wake up if there are such
constant threats that the natives built
a wall and they killed Hanks friend then
waking them up as a forgivable mistake
unless they hibernate for a bunch of
years or something and they woke up
early you can have what Moses he gets to
him when they're still small awesome
fight sequences hijacked by unnecessary
narration you don't want to wake up the
big one why isn't he awake now
apparently these bombs wake up all the
lesser giant creatures but this guy can
sleep through it all because he's
wearing noise-canceling headphones
during his now I was the last of his
kind but he's still growing of course he
is because how else would he eventually
match up with the much larger Godzilla
in the next installation of this
universe but still make this movie
somewhat believable gunpei spent six
years of our lives building this thing I
really would have loved to have seen
more Hank and gun pick because their
adventure contains the most entry how an
American pilot and a Japanese pilot
became friends after being enemies
become friendly with the natives
learning how to survive on an island
full of monsters and gun pays death at
the hands of the skull crawlers it's way
more interesting than everything we've
seen so far while the guys get to work
on fixing the boat mason unhelpfully
tours the village and takes pictures and
I guess sands taking a nap or something
but since that's what this movie thinks
of women's roles in case you're
wondering yes this is the second picture
taking montage featuring a cheesing Bree
Larson in this movie sometimes an enemy
doesn't exist
do you looking for this dialogue is so
stupidly pedantic that I'm starting to
think the script was written by Yogi
Berra so they've got 48 hours to make it
to the North Shore how long could they
have been there then right before they
went out to the boat conrad said as a
refueling team coming to the north end
of the island in three days but now
they're down to 48 hours
this log creature waited a full minute
to wake up while Jack sat down on him
this guy survived way too long for this
to be the end of him I mean in reality
it makes sense that something on the
island would randomly kill him like this
but we've been following this dude
trying to make his way back and three
different scenes like he was gonna be a
major puzzle piece in the plot but nope
it just feels like they were trying to
give Toby Kebbell more face time other
than his workers call I really hope that
thing could call them both can get us
upriver in 36 hours
q movie even if you're saying 12 hours
have passed since they were repairing
the boat they wasted 12 hours Libby
casually introduces an Aurora Borealis
on the island with no sense of wonder
whatsoever
nice dangerous places are always there
nice beautiful I could keep sending this
terrible dialogue line by line but I
don't want subject to you lovely people
to listening to it so I'll just add 10
extra sins to cover the rest of the
movie they just got this in weird boat
made of airplane parts to work and yet
the natives instinctively knew to come
down here and say goodbye to Hank and
here's another story swept to the side
Packard is a sort of Captain Ahab in
this story but all he's allowed to do
for the most part is look real angry
while his men walk through the jungle
basically unharmed except one scene
involving giant spiders also a few
minutes ago Marlow was freaking out
about not being out at night but these
guys were out in the great wide open
with a fully viewable campfire Jesus the
creatures on this island have a terrific
sense of cinematic pacing pterodactyls
wait until everyone is happy to start
attacking huh well that could been worse
I guess also I don't know whether sin or
praise the movie for the most random
death in movie history I'm more annoyed
with how the Sun is always shown in that
Apocalypse Now position on the horizon
during dramatic shots but if we reach
that position and he's not there we
don't send out a search party we're back
here by nightfall understood why does
everybody have to go look for Chapman
why can't it just be Conrad Packard and
maybe two other guys they have to come
back here anyway right in 24 hours if
you have to be on the other side of this
island who the insert stupid cigarette
smoking scenes so that we know this
around here is flammable
this skull crawler vomits chapman's head
and his dog tags only feet away from the
people who are looking for him because
the director thinks using your brain is
for pussies zoom and enhanced cliche
wait a minute this is 1973 right
they don't invent human eyes zoom and
enhance abilities until 2047 and even
then they're spotty at best
why doesn't Conrad pull them back right
this second he's seen the skull on the
ID and can literally show both to the
colonel right now this movie's
aggressively stupid oh no I guess to be
site whether we were rooting for R and s
character or not he's kind of an asshole
but he's also a plan here Wow well see
you John hang on
they were also regular dinosaurs like
Triceratops on the island are we sure
this isn't actually Isla Nublar
these guys suddenly have flamethrowers
that were not part of this movie until
just now alright movie gets into some 2d
side-scrolling action it's like I've got
my Sega Genesis all over again
also luckily these asshole birds have
watched a lot of action movies and think
you can only attack one at the time also
also as we can see here Conrad can see
almost nothing out of this mask but he's
been 100% accurate and slicing these
creatures with a sword but the toxic gas
is still in there gasps doesn't just
stay in one place man it gasses in this
case toxically it's amazing during all
this commotion King Kong never comes by
to see what's up
was super upset when they dropped the
bombs earlier because of the noise but
now he's like out there I'm sorry
colonel pocket Chapman is dead I waited
to tell you this for some reason my
motives are really unclear oh well if
you take away a species natural
competition that proliferate out of
control and we got this insight from the
geologist even though there's a biology
expert standing right next to him keep
your eyes open to ants big ones
yeah ants they sound terrifying too bad
we won't be seeing them in this monster
movie despite being specifically
mentioned it sounds like a bird but it's
a man Jesus john c reilly is such a
national treasure he belongs in a museum
once enough for him being by far the
best human thing about this movie make
him a special gift out of that napalm
just private the baby-faced really need
to test the napalm
it will always do napalm e things it
doesn't miss be around that Ben Conrad
apparently one of the greatest trackers
in the world can't find his way back to
the boat even though they literally just
came from that direction
well just came here to get touched by
brie Larson achievement unlocked piece
wait first till dawn if we're not back
by then just go Ludi gives one last
middle finger to the concept of time
considering that when they docked here
they had 24 hours to get to the
extraction point now they've lost almost
an entire day and night with this bull
but they're still somehow on schedule I
know he's big and strong and all but
Colin survives this I guess come to set
their burning thinking goddamn this
sucks
before deciding finally to walk through
the flames and start Kong it yeah I'm
sure glad brie Larson is in this scene
she brings so much to the table here
stop simply because Mason says stop for
some reason Packard stops even though
there's absolutely no chance of him
changing his mind that's the big one we
were told that the big one would only
surface once Colin was dead so who told
him that Colin was dead or does he have
a heart monitor that tracks him remotely
and erroneously flatlined even though a
severely injured in comatose Kong is
right in front of it the skull crawlers
only impediment to ruling this entire
island this asshole is more interested
in warming up its pipes Tom magically
wakes up in time not to be killed by his
archenemy this movie will remain pg-13
god dammit this is the edge of the
island so it's time for the vertigo
effect for some reason the live your
life
movie seriously thinks it can ring an
emotional human moment out of this
puppet show these things have been going
for the jugular the whole movie but this
one instinctively knows when someone's
trying to sacrifice himself with
grenades so he does the old tail swipe
attack I'd give the movie points for
playing on audience expectations but I'm
Way too pissed at this movie to give it
credit calling grabs a tree is a weapon
but after slamming the skull and
crawlers head into the rocks a few
minutes ago what good does he think a
tree is going to do and the answer is
nothing oh yeah it looked like it hurt
but it was worthless it had one use and
it's done
now what jeez how many ex machina czar
in this movie maybe five I'll get at
five sins for all the ex maka nuts okay
so why does the skull crawler care so
much about the humans anyway the bullets
do him no harm and he's got the wand
motherfucker he's been waiting to kill
Oh wrapped in chains ready to be
destroyed but now this pet has to leave
his life's work to kill some easy
targets not only does this non-military
photographer have perfect aim to hit a
moving target with a goddamn flare gun
this actually distracts this tips from
advancing on the hapless boat why the
fuck is it chasing after Conrad the
shooby thing is over there Colin guesses
correctly where Mason fell and this
murky ass water and is able to grab her
out just in time
villain is dead but comes back for one
more attack cliche but they still have
no time to get to the extraction point
right right mother Jesus how many fuckin
cameras did they take to film this
reunion and Jesus house staged is this
the camera operator gets a shot of Hank
walking inside his own house and they
have all the reaction shots in a real
time nice moment but is this fun fear I
guess this end credits scene is going to
be about Loki's scepter some killed Nick
Fury in this movie so I don't know who's
supposed to give the Avengers their next
assignment Kong is not the only king but
mainly it's Godzilla that's the one
people care about
I'm Billy Mitchell always has a plan
[Music]
everything okay
hey man far as I know to move this
tip-top refuel team will meet us here on
the north end of the island
that may be our only safe departure
window for an unknown period of time sad
good wear helmets when you ride your
bikes you have seatbelts in your cars
you have alarm systems to protect your
homes but what do you do when those
alarms go off crazy is building your ark
after the flood has already come aurora
borealis at this time of year at this
time of day in this part of the country
localized entirely within your kitchen
[Music]
hey this is Fox five we hear you yeah
we're on a boat go on the boat heading
up north on a river boat we're going to
pull together and we're gonna find a way
to get out first we're gonna this is the
end we will be the first to break
through to the other side when you
absolutely positively got to kill every
mother in the room except no substitute
[Music]